and I can't tell you the details but all
I can say is that when I turn in the
script for two the studio gave me three
pages of notes and when I turned in the
script for three they gave me a page of
notes so I was getting better when I
turned in the script for four the studio
executive creative executive over over
the films wrote me an email that said
holy
and and I said well where are the notes
and she said those are the notes it's
been five years of basically unbroken
production right so we started in
September of 17 and we made essentially
completed all production photography and
capture on two basic two and a half
movies so two three first part of four
and then we posted two and now we're
gonna post three and so it won't be 13
years till the next one unless you
should if all everything works out it
should be only another two years oh okay
that's not so that's nothing no not at
all